Let's look at the solution to our multiple predictions quiz.
Branches are result in the third stage which means,
that, we will fetch this branch, and then we will fetch this.
And then we will fetch this. And at that point, this branch will be here and
be resolved. So we will cancel this and this instruction, and
start fetching from X and then Y. So overall, we have wasted two cycles.
Note that this penalty here is the same as if the second instruction here was
not a branch at all. So basically here we actually mis-predicted two branches.
But the second one was mis-predicted in the shadow of the first mis-prediction.
This branch would never have been fetched if we predicted this correctly.
However, the penalty's unaffected. So when we mis-predict a branch,
we just need to worry about getting on the correct path and we pay a penalty for
that, but we don't pay additional penalties. For mis-predicted branches that
themselves should never have been executed because of mis-predictions.
Let's see why this is so. It is because the first branch here results
in flushing the pipeline when it gets to the stage where branches are resolve.
The branch that was fetched after it is at that time here. And
the instruction A is here. And what now happens is,
we flush the pipeline by converting these two into pipeline bubbles. And
next cycle, we will be fetching X. So what happens is really
if a branch has been fetched in error because of a previous mis-prediction,
that branch never gets a chance to cause a pipeline flush, because it
itself gets flushed before that. And that's why we had a two cycle penalty. And
not four cycles of penalty because technically these two were miss predicted.
But really this one should have never been executed in the first place. But
this one was flushed before it could trigger a flush of it's own.